ELIZABETH ANCARANA: So now,
I turn to our panelists.
And thanks again for coming
and talking to our new faculty
here today.
It's just a delight
that you're here.
We have Katia Bertoldi who's
the John L. Loeb Associate
Professor of the
Natural Sciences
at the Johnny Paulson School
of Engineering and Applied
Sciences.
After earning her
Ph.D. in Mechanics
of Materials and Structures
from Trento University in 2006,
Katia did a post-doctoral
fellowship at MIT
and then served as an
Assistant Professor
of Engineering Technology
at the University of Twente
in the Netherlands.
She joined the Harvard
faculty in 2010.
Katia's work focuses
on the relationships
between the internal
structure of a material
and its mechanical properties.
Her research on
materials, especially
those with tunable
properties, has direct use
in many critical fields,
including acoustics, optics,
and electronics.
Next to Katia is
James, or Jay Mitchell
who's is an Associate
Professor of Genetics
and Complex Diseases at the
Harvard T.H. Chan School
of Public Health.
After completing his
doctoral training
at the University of California
at Berkeley on Human Telomerase
Biochemistry, he did his
post-doctoral studies
also in the Netherlands at
Erasmus University in Rotterdam
where he focused on the genetics
of DNA repair and aging.
Jay came to Harvard
in 2008, where
since, he's been focusing on
the restriction of calorie
or nutrient intake
to increase stressed
resistance, particularly
during major surgery,
and the improvement
of metabolic fitness
and the extension of longevity.
We also have
Lawrence Ralph, who's
the John L. Loeb Associate
Professor of the Social
Sciences in the
Departments of Anthropology
and African and African-American
studies in the Faculty of Arts
and Sciences.
After earning his
Ph.D. In Anthropology
from the University
of Chicago in 2010,
Lawrence served as
a Mandela Rodney
Dubois a post-doctoral
fellow at the Center
for African and
Afro-American studies
at the University of Michigan.
He then joined the
Harvard faculty in 2011.
His scholarly work explores how
the historical circumstances
of police abuse, mass
incarceration, and the drug
trade [? naturalized ?]
disease, disability,
and premature death
for urban residents,
showing how violence
and injury play
a central role in the daily
lives of black urbanites.
So we have a nice array,
a very interesting array
of work and backgrounds.
Each panelist will speak
for about 10 minutes,
and then we'll open it up to
questions from the audience.
So would you want to
maybe start with Katia?
KATIA BERTOLDI: Yes.
OK.
So first of all, welcome
to everybody to Harvard.
So I was here in 2010,
so a long time ago.
So as Elizabeth told you, I
started in January 2010-- no,
sorry, it was in 2009
because I started in 2010.
So now you might think
it's a long time ago.
But you'll see, time will fly.
And soon you will be on this
side of the table speaking
to a new faculty.
So what do I remember
of the first days?
The first days are kind
of mixed feeling, right?
At least for me was.
On one hand, you
feel the pressure.
On the other hand, you
would like to do things,
but you don't know what to do
and you don't know how to move.
And then, you need to adjust.
Adjust to the new place.
In my case, I was
moving back from Europe,
so you need to fix
your family life.
My husband needed to find a job.
So all these sort of different
pressure coming to you.
So what can you do
to deal with that?
So I think the best
suggestion I got was,
before coming here,
I was deciding
whether to leave Europe and come
here and to accept this offer
or not.
And my mentor in the Netherlands
just told me, look, Katia.
This is a unique opportunity.
We know that there's
going to be-- probably
you're going to
have some pressure.
It's going to be tough.
But it's really unique.
And there, you have
the opportunity
really to do great things
because mostly the environment.
The people around
you, the resources.
It's a seven year period
that is tenure, yes.
It's not so easy to get tenure.
But forget about it, and
try to enjoy every day,
and really to make sure that
at the end of the seven years,
you can say it was
worth doing it.
And just make sure that you
take advantage of the resources.
And this, I think, was the
best advice I really got.
So try it try to
forget about the fact
that there's going
to be a promotion.
There's going to be
several promotions.
One in between, and
then the final one.
And just really take
advantage of the resources.
Now how of take
advantage of resources.
So in my case, I was lucky
because people in my area--
so I'm in the School of
Engineering and Applied
Sciences.
So people working in an area
related to my area of expertise
go for lunch together every day.
I was the only junior faculty.
Now there are a couple more.
But this has been
very, very helpful.
It's true that maybe you waste
one hour of your day every day,
noon to 1:00.
And maybe you could write
a paper or do something.
But now I realize
how important it
has been because in this
informal discussion,
you get to learn how
people move around.
And I was assigned, as
probably most of you,
to a mentoring committee
at the very beginning.
Honestly, because of
these informal lunches,
daily informal lunches
and discussion,
I never used the
committee just because I
have this informal
committee every day.
And I find it much more
useful, because after a while,
after you go for
lunch every day,
you can also ask these
sort of questions
that maybe are intimidating.
You don't want to ask to
somebody that you just
meet once a year.
So this has been
quite helpful for me.
And what else can I tell you?
Clearly, at the
beginning for me was also
difficult to suddenly
manage so many tasks.
Before, I was a post-doc.
I was a faculty for a
while in the Netherlands.
But there, the environment
was very different.
I was sort of a senior
post-doc because the structure
of the academic system
is very different.
So suddenly, I was pretty
much spending all my time
doing research.
And then when I started
here, suddenly I
had to manage a group.
I have currently 20
people in my group.
So it's a medium-sized
group, I would say.
You need to write grant to
make sure that you get money
to support the group.
You need to teach, mentoring
these people, and write papers.
So it took me a couple
of months to adjust.
But then what I figured out
was in my case very useful.
Every morning when
I wake up, I just
try to make a list of
things on a piece of paper
and just cross lines during
the day as things move.
And make sure that
I try to balance
all the different things,
because sometimes, I
have the tendency
only to focus on one.
And then it's 5:00
PM, and suddenly you
realize you have to
do other three things.
So trying to find a
balance is always useful.
Beginning, I found it
particularly difficult
to manage students
and manage post-docs.
So maybe I was a bit unlucky.
At the beginning, I had some
cases that were not so easy.
Also, this was
also because of me,
because probably
at the beginning,
I was not so sure about
the quality [INAUDIBLE]
into the people I was hiring.
So I can see that now,
over time, I improve a lot.
Now I can select people
in a much better way,
and I'm much more sure
that the people I'm hiring
are exactly what I expect.
But you learn by mistakes.
So I spend quite
a bit of time also
dealing with managing people.
I didn't take much advantage
of the resources around campus
that I-- I just mostly talk with
senior colleagues around me.
And this was after
I solved the cases,
and to try to basically
smooth out all the issues,
I figured it out.
Something I found
particularly useful
was to try to put
a limit on travel.
So at the beginning, I look
at this as a compromise
with my husband.
Clearly you can travel, and you
can spend almost all your time
on planes and visiting
beautiful places.
And not only visiting, but also
giving talks at conferences.
But you also need--
life is a compromise.
So clearly, my husband was
not at all up for that.
And so we realized, OK,
why don't we try to limit.
We came up with
sort of agreement,
let's try to limit the
travel to once a month.
It's not a strict rule.
But let's try [INAUDIBLE].
Sometimes it's two.
Sometime it's zero.
Sometimes maybe three,
but try to put some limit.
A cap, at least.
At the beginning,
I look at that,
I thought a fine compromise,
but a limitation.
Now what I realize is
that helped me a lot.
The fact that I need to
think where I want to go
and I need to think
why I want to go,
and I need to be selective,
because traveling
is tiring and takes
out time that you need
to spend doing other things.
So I find it really-- now
that when I look back,
I'm thinking that this
is helping me a lot.
So basically
compromising between all
the different tasks.
So still keep visibility,
but also being very selective
and making sure that you choose
where to go in such a way
that you maximize some
of the visibility.
And make sure that you meet the
people that you need to meet
and you want to meet.
And yeah, I don't know.
What else do you
want me to tell you?
ELIZABETH ANCARANA: Well,
that's a good start.
Maybe we'll have
each panelist talk,
and then we'll open
it up to questions.
JAMES MITCHELL: Yeah, OK.
I'll take over then.
Jay Mitchell from the
School of Public Health.
I was going to
apologize at the outset
because I'm a
research scientist.
I run a lab.
And I thought that might
be not so common with what
people in the
Engineering School do,
but perhaps not so different.
So I'm going to take you
through some of the things
that I've done over the last
eight years that have gotten me
to this point, and some of
the lessons I've learned.
So what Elizabeth told
you, just to refresh
on what I do specifically,
basic research lab.
I'm trained in genetics
and biochemistry.
And my lab focuses on
aging and nutrition,
and the mechanism by which, when
you eat less, you live longer.
That is you if
you were a rodent.
And we work on mice primarily.
Or if you were a fly or a yeast,
the same thing holds true.
But what I actually
do is study how
the mechanisms that allow
you to live longer actually
increase your stress resistance.
And that turns out to be
very handy when you have
a planned stress in your life.
And so what we actually
work on is surgery.
And we're trying to figure
out what you should--
or in this case,
shouldn't eat-- before you
go into a major surgery to
increase your body's resistance
to stress.
So that's what I do.
And the reason I tell you that
is because the first key lesson
I learned at Harvard
is to be able to define
what you do in two sentences.
And it has to be
hopefully exciting,
and it has to sound
really important.
And most importantly,
you have to be the best
person in the world at that.
So you really have to
define your niche carefully.
And I still struggle with
that, because my lab actually
does a lot more than just that.
We work on different
organisms, different pathways.
And I continually struggle with
how exactly to define my niche,
my role.
To make myself that most
important person doing
that most important thing.
But I think it's a good lesson.
And for me, learning
that lesson has
helped with a lot of other
aspects of the business that
are very important.
Publishing, for example.
Getting grants.
It's easier to publish and
get grants based on things
that people know that
you're the best at.
Things that they trust
that you know how to do.
When you get outside
of your core business,
you're area of focus, people
don't have that trust.
They don't know you.
And unfortunately, a
lot of this business
is based on personal
interactions.
Who you know, their
judgment of you personally.
So it's enormously helpful
just to keep that focus.
What is your core business?
What do you work on?
What are you the best at?
And build out from there.
Not easy, but very important.
So a corollary to
that is writing.
And I wasn't a particularly
good writer coming in,
and I've really had
to sharpen my skills.
Communication in general.
I wasn't a very good speaker.
And I've tried to
sharpen my skills.
These days, it's
not good enough just
to write well and
speak well, but I
think you have to
be even more clever
with social media and other ways
of getting your message out.
So the more often you
can get your message out,
I think it does have benefits.
And this can be at
meetings, traveling, perhaps
in the public realm.
The media itself, sometimes
they find something
you do interesting.
And you can try to use them as
a route to convey your message
and how interesting it is,
and how it should be funded,
for example, by the NIH.
That's a bit of a
double-edged sword,
too, because the media can
take what you do and twist it
into something else.
But it's by and large
probably worth it
to try to get that
attention on what you do.
So that's the key lesson, the
two sentence, the elevator
pitch.
Setting up a lab.
An assistant professor is like
a small business entrepreneur.
You have to run a group.
You have to obtain funding.
You get your investor.
The university gives you,
in our case, about two
and a half, three years.
At least that's how it
was eight years ago.
But you probably
have no training--
at least if you're a
geneticist like me,
you're not trained in
organizational skills.
You're not trained in finance.
And you're certainly not trained
in choosing people or managing
them.
And for me, that's been
the biggest struggle
is to choose good people.
Of course, Harvard's wonderful.
The students, the
post-docs, even
the technicians that we have
access to is tremendous.
But I really wish I had
a sixth sense to know,
that's the one that's
a good fit for my lab.
A mutual good fit.
And I don't.
And talking to my colleagues,
even the senior ones,
they get better.
But I don't think anybody really
has the secret to choosing
people that are a good match.
But we keep trying.
Grants after the three year
start-up package runs out
fund everything, including,
in my case, 70% of my salary
is through my grant.
So that's primarily what I do
these days is write for grants.
But of course, to get grants,
you need to have the papers.
And for the papers,
you need to choose
the good people, the
students, the postdocs who
then deliver the data.
And it's that
preliminary data, then,
that allows you
to get the grant.
So it's just a revolving circle.
And where do you start?
You come in here.
It's your first year.
I've seen two different
patterns that people follow
to break into the business.
One is to hire senior
people, a senior lab
manager or technician,
senior postdocs,
and to have a very
high burn rate.
Just churn out
mature data rapidly,
and then enter the
publications and the grants.
I chose a fundamentally
different route--
to do everything
myself very slowly,
and to learn and make all
the mistakes along the way.
I think both paths
can be successful.
It probably just depends
on your personality.
So there are unfortunately
no generalizations
that I can make.
I've seen both succeed,
I've seen both fail.
The one thing that I can
say is choosing my path,
at least I do know
how to do everything.
And also coming
from Europe, there
was some necessity
to that because I
didn't have any idea
how things here worked.
So that's maybe situational.
But I think those
two paths can work.
Taking advantage of resources.
Of course, as we've
heard, they're tremendous.
And I already
mentioned the students,
and we heard from Alan
Garber, the faculty are also
wonderful resources not
just for what you do,
but for things that are
tangentially related,
which might have some
influence at some point.
Collaboration is
a wonderful thing,
but I'll give one example
for me that it was enormously
enriching.
But I entered it with
a false pretenses
of what I thought I
might get out of it.
So being in the School
of Public Health--
and we have a Department of
Immunology and Infectious
Diseases-- I struck
up a collaboration
with a biologist who
works on malaria,
which I know nothing about.
We were interested in
how what the host eats--
and the host being the mouse,
in this case-- how what they eat
affects the course of disease.
And we found some really
interesting stuff.
Namely, that if you
restrict food intake,
you don't succumb
to the illness.
So very interesting.
And I thought,
this is wonderful.
It's really enriched how I
think about my core business.
But the mistake I made is to
think that I could turn that
into another core business.
And that has been
enormously difficult.
To go, then, to different study
sections, different journals
who don't know me.
I'm not a malaria guy.
And to try to recapitulate
the same thing
that I'm doing in my core
didn't work out, in my case.
That was my expectation,
to diversify my funding.
And it was a false expectation.
I keep trying, because
it's really interesting.
And so I would say
the take home was
that it was so interesting
and so enriching
for my core business that
it was totally worth doing.
But it's hard to
predict ahead of time.
So I just don't have
false expectations of what
you might get out of it.
Equipment is another thing maybe
specific to the lab sciences.
But it's all out there.
You just have to figure
out where, and who to ask,
and how to ask.
And I don't have any good
advice except for perhaps things
like this.
So if there's anybody
who has a GC that
detects hydrogen sulfide, I
would love to talk to you.
It's worth a try.
Navigating the
Harvard environment,
there is very little here
that is as it appears.
And you get to learn that
probably pretty quickly.
You've probably already
figured that out.
So for me, mentorship
was really a key
to surviving this
opaque environment.
And mentorship from
the tenured faculty
was enormously helpful
in figuring out how
the school, the School of Public
Health and the university,
how they interact.
How that works.
What's important, where
I should spend my time.
But wasn't really
helpful for how
to climb the tenure ladder
because they had done it
in a different era.
So for that, getting to know
your colleagues who are just
one step above you is
enormously helpful,
because it's different,
I think, now that it
was even five or 10 years ago.
Lastly, the relationship
with your department chair,
who you can't,
choose, by the way.
It's like kids and parents.
You're here already.
You've got a department chair.
But it really is of
critical importance.
Although I don't
see my department
chair except once a month
at faculty meetings.
He's also my formal
adviser, so I
see him annually to discuss
mentorship-related items.
But my relationship
with him it's
critical if I run
into a gap in funding.
It's going to be my
department chair who's going
to pull me through or not.
He's the one who sets the
pace of the tenure ladder.
So again, it's not
something you control,
but it's certainly
something you should be
aware of, at least in my case.
And I've heard this
in other institutions
in the lab sciences, too,
of the critical importance
of your relationship with
your department chair.
Finally, a piece of advice.
And I think we just
heard it from Katia.
Don't worry about
the tenure too much.
In our case, it's a
10 to 11 year process.
So maybe it's easier
for me to say.
I have other colleagues who
it's a five to six year process,
and that seems far
more stressful.
But in any case, with
the longer clocks,
you can really say-- I
can say in all honesty,
possibly I'll get another job
with a bigger salary running
a department somewhere
before I make tenure.
That's something I see happens
to my colleagues all the time.
Another thing that might happen
is you run out of funding
and you don't have to
worry about it anyway.
But hopefully you
will enjoy, you'll
find a good work-life balance.
And that period of
time, you won't just
be focused on making tenure,
but you'll actually learn
and enrich yourself
during that period.
LAURENCE RALPH: Hi.
Again, I'm Laurence Ralph.
I'm in the Department
of Anthropology
and African and
African-American Studies.
I guess I'll begin by just
reaffirming some of the things
that the panelists
have said, and offering
some concrete details.
I think the first thing is
use the people around you
as a resource.
I think not only
professionally, but personally.
One of the biggest
things in my first year
was that the people that
I met in orientation
in this Institute as
well became people
that I would hang out
with for happy hours
or what have you because we
were all new to Cambridge.
And we were all going
through the same process
at the same time.
And we still have
sustained relationships.
So I think that's
a critical thing.
Or at least it has been for me.
The second thing I'll say
is that my first year, I
had a striking experience
at this very faculty club.
And it wasn't during
this Institute,
but shortly after, when my
department had an event here.
And we were upstairs
in one of these rooms,
and there were
waiters with gloves on
and silver trays passing
out lobsters or something
like that.
And it was like a glee
club in the background.
And I was looking around,
and I was like, where am I?
And I had just came from the
University of Michigan State,
a state school.
And just as I'm
having this thought,
like, what is this place?
One of my colleagues said,
man, before the recession,
we got two lobsters.
And I couldn't believe it.
I say that to say that there
will be moments like that
here at Harvard.
And those moments can
intimidate you, right?
Because at the same time, you
need to interact with people.
And what's especially
jarring is the juxtaposition
between those moments
and the conversations
that you have with people who
are actually down to earth
and friendly and funny.
But you might not think so in
particular environments here.
So I would say that
that's an important thing
to remember because again,
the people in your department
are resources that you can
turn to for particular things,
right?
I'm in two departments, so
I've had different takes
on how Harvard operates.
And even how a
department operates,
relationship with the chair
of the department and what
have you.
And what's interesting is
that in terms of things
like mentoring, there's no
real one fixed way that you can
expect to be mentored, I think.
In both of my
departments, mentoring
has been really active
at particular moments.
And you can tell that senior
colleagues had a discussion
about, this is what we're
going to do about mentoring,
and they've
implemented something.
But at other moments,
it's not been on the radar
in the same way.
And it's oscillated
between both departments.
So I would say that what's
presented to you now
might not be how it
is in the long run.
So it's important to take
advantage of the opportunities
that you have, particularly
around mentorship, because they
might not always be there.
One faculty member might
be really into mentorship,
and that might be her
thing or his thing.
And they might be
driving the other faculty
members towards that direction.
But they might be on leave
the next year or something
like that.
So you don't know how
it's going to pan out.
I think in light of that,
one of the best ways
to approach a mentorship, I
think, is around your research,
and around your
area of expertise.
And soliciting feedback
on what you do.
And I think this
goes back to what
Jay says about
knowing your strengths
and knowing who you
are as a scholar,
and branding yourself,
for lack of a better word,
as the type of scholar
that you want to be.
I think that particularly
around if you're
writing a paper, if you're
writing a book chapter--
my field is a book field.
But also, when you're
applying to grants or things
like that, when you can have
concrete things to share
with people and
solicit their feedback,
it can be a way both to get
help on what you're writing,
but also a way for
them to know what
you do so when
they see articles,
they might send it to you.
Or when something comes
across in the news,
you might have those
happenstance conversations
about that particular area or
that particular research topic.
And I think that it's
especially critical coming
from another university, or if
this is your first job coming
from graduate school
where you have
a built in network
of your cohort,
or you have a built in
network of your dissertation
committee or
something like that,
this is like-- I would think
of it as reconstituting
another network of
scholars that can help you
in the next phase
of your career.
And there's particular--
at least in the Faculty
of Arts and Sciences,
there's particular centers
that can help you with that.
One is the FAS Research
Administration Services.
And I would assume that other
schools have similar things,
where if you have a grant,
they can not only give you
an idea of what kind of
things that you can apply for
based on your topic, but
also what faculty members are
doing similar research.
So they'll put you in touch
with different faculty members,
even in different
schools, actually.
You can get a letter
of collaboration
that can help your grant
and things like that.
Another thing is the various
centers around Harvard
could be a way to
present your research
and develop organic
relationships in that way
with faculty that are
doing similar things.
And I would say that
developing this kind of network
can be a way of thinking
about Harvard as a home
base for your research
agenda, right?
What I mean is that it can
be quite daunting to think
about yourself as
a researcher that
has to have a public
presence, that
has to have a website, that
has to have Twitter, Facebook,
and all of these things
that-- not only are you
doing research, but there's
more and more obligation
to present your research
to the wider world.
Make it accessible to
the wider world in ways
that we're often
not trained to do.
In ways in which we are not
necessarily comfortable doing.
But I think one way is to
think about it as, what
are the various ways that you
can just promote your research
around the university, right?
And that's less daunting, right?
Can you develop a relationship
with the Harvard Magazine,
or the Crimson or
something like that
that can also promote your
research in a different way
that's not at the same scale,
in a way that allows students
and colleagues
around the university
to know about your research,
know about your research
agenda, and have these
organic conversations.
And just a quick
story on that note
is that the last research
grant that I received,
it was different in the sense
that your department had
to nominate you for the grant.
Then it went up the
ladder and the provost
had to select different
applications out
of the nominations
from each department.
And then it went to
the granting agency.
But in my case, the reason
why my department chair
knew that this grant would
be great for me, that
was a great fit
for my research was
because I had just shared with
him a NSF application, right?
And so he had read
the NSF application.
He had wrote a letter of
support for the NSF application.
And that application
wasn't successful.
But this other grant was
that was particularly
for my research topic, right?
And he wouldn't have
known that and had that
on the forefront
of his mind if I
hadn't been active about
sharing my research,
and sharing my research
interest with him
at that particular
moment in time.
So I think that it's
never a lost cause when
you try to build a network.
It might take time
and it might take
energy and things that are
kind of difficult that you
don't always have.
But I think that in the
end, it will pay off
for your ultimate
research goals.
ELIZABETH ANCARANA: Thank you.
OK, lots of great, great advise.
And just to follow up on what
you were saying, Lawrence.
There's also a
resource available.
It's open access.
It was created in our
office a few years ago.
Faculty finder.
So you could just even
Google Harvard faculty finder
and it'll come up.
Or the office website
is faculty.Harvard.edu.
And there are lots of resources
available to you there as well.
But Harvard faculty
finder on faculty finder,
you can find other
faculty at Harvard
that are working on similar
research topics as yours.
And that's a way to develop your
network around your scholarship
as well.
Do we have questions for
any one of our panelists?
And we have a [INAUDIBLE]
mic that's coming around.
SPEAKER 1: I have a question.
This is for Jay or any
of the other panelists
if they want to
give a stab at it.
So I want to follow
up on the comment you
made about being an
assistant professor
or running a new lab essentially
as being a small entrepreneur
and running a startup, which is
something that I've read about.
And one thing I wanted to ask
is, how does this analogy carry
over to getting funding?
So from the perspective
of this analogy, what
does it mean about how
proactive one must be,
or what kind of
strategies, essentially,
one could use to get
your venture funded.
JAMES MITCHELL:
Right, so the rules
used to be that you
can rely on the NIH
for biomedical research.
And now you have to diversify.
So I think we try to
train our post-docs,
and even our students
these days-- I
wasn't trained in this way.
But to always think about a
strategy to take those data
and turn them into more money.
And that can be in the form
of NIH grants, of course.
It can be in the form
of foundational support
for some disease.
It can even be from
corporate sponsorship.
And Harvard is
fantastic at bringing
in corporations who are
interested in funding research
at Harvard.
And I've recently been able
to take advantage of one
of those types of grants.
So the idea is about
diversification of funding.
And I made the comment
about the department chair
is the one who, if you
can't make payroll,
they're the one who'll bail you
out, because that's how it is.
You can see things--
NIH grants at least last
typically around four years.
So you can see it coming.
But it's not something that
you can turn around rapidly.
So it could take you a year
or two to get one renewed.
But I think the people prepare
a certain way these days.
You just take this into account.
You're going to
have to diversify
beyond the traditional
sources, and be creative.
I've heard on the radio
about crowdsourcing
of certain things.
It hasn't come to that
for us, but I think
we all have open minds now.
And I have to say, I don't think
it compromises our research
at all.
It's the same data,
the same interest.
A lot of what I do is
obviously translational.
If somebody wants to pay
for that, that's great.
And I don't see that as
compromising our mission
at all.
KATIA BERTOLDI: Can
I add something?
So on a very practical
side, [INAUDIBLE]
very different strategies.
So I've seen young
colleagues basically
say, OK, I'm going to
write one grant per month.
Even two grants per month.
And I've seen them
sticking to this plan.
And some of them have
been very successful.
Some of them, not so successful.
I've seen colleagues instead
be more strategic and say,
let's first collect-- let's
put together a very good idea.
Let's refine this idea.
Let's maybe have some
preliminary contact
also with managers, with
NSF Manager, NIH manager,
and make sure that
what I'm going to write
is likely to be funded.
Again, also in this case,
you're never sure, right?
But also in this case, I've seen
50% of this class of colleague
being successful, and 50% not.
So I believe there is not really
a single path to go around it.
And also, something I found
very useful, anyway, in my case,
is money from industry.
So don't forget to talk to
also people outside academia,
outside funding
agency, because if you
are able to start
the right relations
and meet the right people, that
might be very, very useful.
ELIZABETH ANCARANA: We
had another question.
SPEAKER 2: Question for anyone.
How close to the vest
or not close to the vest
do you keep your ideas,
or intellectual property.
I hate that term for what we do.
But intellectual property-- I've
seen senior faculty, and not
even senior faculty be very
secretive with things they're
working on, and that
makes me kind of sad
as someone in academia.
At the same time, I had
lunch with a friend of mine.
She's a post-doc and she
applied for a faculty job
at another institution.
And a couple months later, the
chair of that search committee
didn't talk about the job but
said, oh, can you look at this
grant that I'm writing.
It's basically an idea that
came from her application.
And then I thought back
a couple months ago,
where Professor x
from Institution y
said, oh, what are you
working on these days?
And I kind of said, well, I'm
thinking about this new space.
And they're like, well
send me what you have.
I'd love to just look at it.
And I didn't send anything,
but I was like, oh no.
What did-- that
makes me kind of sad.
So how did you think
about that at all.
LAURENCE RALPH: Yeah, I can
say a few words on that.
I think the fields are
a little bit different,
but I think on
things like this, it
can be kind of
counter-intuitive in the sense
that if more people
know about your work,
I think it's less likely that
somebody takes your idea.
But if you keep it
close to the vest,
it could be more likely because
the person that you shared it
with could then take it.
So I think that speaks towards
getting your ideas out there,
having them in circulation,
presenting your ideas.
And I also think that
you're here for a reason.
You're here because they
believed in what you do.
And so I think that
they ultimately
want you to develop that core
sense of your research agenda.
So I think that you have
to have conversations
with your colleagues about
these kind of things.
And getting your
ideas out there.
I think can help.
JAMES MITCHELL: Just a quick
note from my perspective.
We've all heard these
stories, and they're real.
These things do happen.
And I think it's
a risk assessment.
You have more to
gain, or more to lose.
And I like to say that,
for the most part,
I think I have more
to gain by sharing.
That being said, people
are creatures of habit
and do develop reputations
for doing these things.
So to some degree, that can be
part of your risk assessment.
You can find out-- if
somebody's specifically
asking about an idea of yours,
that it's in an idea state,
check it out.
SPEAKER 2: Thoughts, Katia?
KATIA BERTOLDI:
No, I totally agree
with what Laurence and Jay say.
Typically I tend to be open.
I know there is some risk
associated with that,
but I really think that the
advantages in being open
are much larger and much
more than the disadvantages,
because what you
want to make sure
is that people know
about what you're doing.
And if you are very secretive,
and you keep everything
as a secret, people
don't get to know.
And maybe then you really
run the risk of somebody
get the same idea without
knowing what you're doing,
and they get it.
JAMES MITCHELL: Last thought.
People love collaborating
with Harvard.
So if they're from
without, it can definitely
be used to your advantage.
SPEAKER 3: I just
had a question.
I was reflecting on all the
various things you said,
and in some sense, it's, no
offense, a bit of a downer.
I was curious if you could speak
to-- the point of this exercise
is to have fun on some
level, and to live
an interesting life.
And I was wondering what things
you've done over the years
to preserve the actual point
of the exercise in the face
of worrying about money, and
worrying about promotion,
and all of that.
How do you keep the joy?
KATIA BERTOLDI: Well, I'm
still proud when I meet people
outside Harvard in the evening.
And after a while, they
ask me, what's your job.
And I tell them what I'm doing.
They're very surprised.
And what I always
tell my husband,
the day they assume I'm a
faculty, I'm going to quit.
So I think it's possible to
keep a level of joy inside,
and to combine it with
an academic career
and with your job.
And also, within the job,
I think it's a lot of fun.
I really enjoy interacting
with the students.
And I'm probably more fun now
than when I was a post-doc
and I was doing the research.
I was in the lab by myself.
Now I'm in the lab only
over summer a few times.
Most of my time, I'm in my
office writing or a meeting
with people.
But it's still a lot
of-- it's even more fun
because now I have the ability
to work on multiple projects
and develop more ideas, and to
work with these extremely smart
people, it's just amazing.
LAURENCE RALPH: Yeah, I would
echo some of those comments.
I think that the people
in both of my departments
are leading figures of
the kind of research
I do in different ways.
And so the ability to have
just conversations with them,
the ability to pick
their brain, the ability
to get concrete feedback from
them is actually enjoyable,
and it's actually helped me
personally and professionally
as well.
And so I think that things
loom large in the background.
But I think that being here
and having the platform that we
have and having the kind
of interactions that we
have is a humbling experience.
It's a fun experience.
And also, just the
amount of people
that circulate through
Harvard at any given semester,
let alone a year, is a
really, really fun experience.
And you really have the
resources to just imagine
what you want to happen.
There's no person
that I can think
of that I couldn't imagine
inviting to Harvard, period.
That includes, I don't
know, entertainers.
It includes scholars.
It includes athletes.
It includes anybody who
I would want to meet.
And I think it's not out
of the realm of possibility
that they would
accept an invitation.
And so I think being able to
have that kind of imagination
is fun.
It's part of the reason
why I wanted to be
a professor in the first place.
ELIZABETH ANCARANA: Jay, do
you want to add anything?
JAMES MITCHELL: I'd just
echo these sentiments.
Doing research is
what drives me,
and this is the best place
in the world to do it.
And that makes me very happy.
And I feel very lucky
to be able to do that.
STEPHEN GRAY: I have a question.
Stephen Gray.
I have a question
to sort of follow up
on that one that relates
to balance and time
management and joy.
Being someone-- I just recently
came from private practice
and I had a half time
appointment at MIT.
But primarily, my contribution
was through my practice.
So now I'm moving fully into
the academic realm, which is
a little bit different for me.
But I also have a young
child, and I have a partner.
My wife, who would
love to make sure
that she sees me
at the same hour
all the time in some
sort of predictable way.
So what do people do for
balance with their partners
and their children,
and carving out time
strategically to do the things
that we need to do in order
to push thinking in our
respective disciplines?
JAMES MITCHELL: I'll
take a stab at that.
I have three kids who are in
the middle school to high school
range.
And I think one of the biggest
advantages of being in academia
is you can set your
own schedule, largely.
I don't travel that
much by choice.
So I can do all
the little things
that many of my colleagues
in other fields can't do.
I can go to breakfast shares.
I can go to plays in
the middle of the day.
I can do all those little things
that cumulatively, I think,
really enrich my life.
KATIA BERTOLDI: I think one of
the big advantages of academia
is flexibility.
But then we need also to
be very careful about that
because my husband
has an industrial job.
So it's 7:00 to 5:00.
At 5:00, they get out
and it's over, right?
And then you start
the day after.
When you have a
flexible job, you
have the tendency
to run over, right?
And there's so much to do.
But I think at a
certain point, it's
important to recognize that even
if you spend eight days a week
and 48 hours a day,
it's not enough to do
what you should do.
[INAUDIBLE]
There are limits.
And you need to
accept your limits.
And apparently, it's not
possible to do everything
you would like to do.
And just accept that, and try
to find a good compromise.
And it's also true that the
tenure process is quite long.
In Engineering School,
it's seven years.
It might be longer,
but probably I
don't think it might
be much shorter.
So maybe you want to spend--
if it's one month time period,
you're willing to spend all the
period just doing one thing.
But for seven years,
it's 1/10 of your life.
So it's really important to make
sure you find a good balance.
ELIZABETH ANCARANA:
Question here?
SPEAKER 4: Thank you.
My question is directed
to all the panelists,
but I think it's
gets a little bit
to the point around networking.
And it's about how
much time you try
to dedicate-- if there's a
specific amount of time--
to engagement in non-research
or non-academic activities
within your
departments or schools.
And I'm specifically thinking
about committee engagement.
I have two extremes.
I have a secondary
appointment in the Department
of Biostatistics where
literally in any given week,
I'll get three requests
for committee membership
of academics or
curriculum that would take
five hours a week for months.
On the other extreme, in
my primary appointment
in the Department of Global
Health and Social Medicine,
I know these committees exist,
but there's no open invitation
to join them.
And I'm just wondering,
one, how much
do you value these
memberships in committees
both in terms of your
professional enjoyment,
but also your
professional advancement.
Two, do you have a set
idea of how much time
you would want to try to
commit to those activities?
How do you balance that
when you, like you said,
have so many things that
you're trying to balance.
And then three, are
there any committees
that you've just really
learned a lot from,
or that you would recommend
that junior faculty get involved
in because they can learn
a lot about the underbelly
of the school, or
how things work,
or how promotion
committees work.
LAURENCE RALPH: Yeah,
I'll take a stab at that.
For me, it's been trial
and error, actually.
Just figuring it out.
I think my approach
has been committees
that-- particularly when it's
outside of the department
or the departments that I'm
in, just wider FAS committees,
it's been things that I enjoy,
and that I know that will
nourish me in a different way.
So I'm on the committee
for public service.
And I think thinking
through those ideas
around public service
and meeting students who
are interested in public
service in particular,
I think that is fun for me.
Or women and gender
studies, or ethnic studies.
So basically, I'm
on committees that
enhance my research interests
outside of what I specifically
do.
But as far as committees
for the department,
I think setting limits is
a good idea, especially
for me in two departments.
I think that it's
fine to say that I'm
on this number of committees
in this department,
and this on this, so I really
can't take anything on.
Or there's committees
that are only
particular to specific
times of the year
that you can plan
to manage, or manage
your time in different ways.
Prize committees are like that.
So if you're on a
prize committee,
it's really at the
end of the year
that you would
have to read a lot.
But it's only sustained
for a couple of weeks,
and then it's over.
So you could do that.
Like the Hoopes Prize
is one of those things
where it's actually enjoyable.
You actually get to read
a lot of different theses
from students
doing amazing work.
And it's a lot of
work, but it's a lot
of work for a particular amount
of time, and then it's over.
And this same thing with
selection committees
for graduate school when you're
admitting graduate students.
That's a particular
time of the year,
at the end of the
first semester.
But once you're done
that, it's kind of done.
And that way, you can be a good
citizen to your department,
but you're not in
committees where
you have to meet on a regular
basis for the whole year.
And so I would
think strategically
about the kinds of committees
that you like personally.
The ones-- what kind of time
commitment they take up.
When in the year they take
up those time commitments.
But at the end of
the day, I think
it's trial and error,
because you'll figure out
which ones that you
enjoy, and which ones
that you don't want to do.
And it's really a personal
thing on many levels,
whether you enjoy
curriculum or you
enjoy hands on
student committees,
or you enjoy things like that.
JAMES MITCHELL: No
is a full sentence.
For me, it's very
difficult to say,
and I think the advice from
Laurence is really good.
But even some committees-- the
one I least like to serve on
is the IACUC committee, the
animal ethical committee.
It's a huge time commitment.
But I'd have to say, I've
learned a tremendous amount
from that one.
Not just about the business
itself, but also because it's
on a Harvard Medical area, the
Longwood Medical area level.
So it's closer to a
university level committee.
And that's been really
interesting starting
as a young assistant
professor who naively accepts
an offer from his department
chairman who said,
oh, it's just a
few times a year.
Really not a big deal.
So it was a hidden opportunity,
I would say, to learn a lot.
SPEAKER 5: So
actually, following up
on that exact point.
I'm curious to know what
your strategies have
been around the art of saying
no, whether it's committee
meetings or service,
maybe guest lecturing,
or doing review
articles or chapters.
How have you all
navigated saying
no, particularly to senior level
people within your departments?
KATIA BERTOLDI: It's not easy.
It's not easy.
So at the beginning, I
was afraid to say no.
And so I said a lot of yes.
But then I ran into trouble.
Big trouble, because
I was over-committed,
and then I was not able to
deliver what I promised.
So quickly realized
that that was
much worse than saying
no at the very beginning,
because if you say yes, then
the person expects something
from you.
And then, you need to deliver.
So I quickly realized that.
Fortunately, at the beginning,
you have the excuse,
you're young.
So you can use the excuse,
sorry, I over-committed.
I didn't realize that.
And come out with this
sort of apologies.
So if you say too
many yes, you will
learn at a certain point
you need to say no.
But I think it's better to say
no from the very beginning, so
yeah.
LAURENCE RALPH:
So some strategies
that are complicated that
I've had trouble with.
One is the deferral strategy,
because people do remember
and they do ask you later.
So that one doesn't always work.
I think setting limits
actually is a good one in terms
of-- this is what I've
committed to for the year,
and I can't do anything
above that in order
to do what I have to do.
I think people understand that.
And that goes for, I
think, travel as well,
like when people are
inviting you to things.
You'll get suddenly
a lot of invitations,
and setting limits.
Really thinking intentionally
of how many times
this semester am I going
to leave or go out of town,
or something like
that, because that
will affect your ability to
deliver what you promised here
as well.
And I think one of the
biggest strategies,
though, is asking people
how to say no, too.
I think this office is good
at giving advice about that.
Like you can ask somebody,
or even ask a mentor,
what kinds of things can I say
no to, and what kinds of things
are really good for me to
do, or expected of me to do?
Or if you can't
actually do something.
A lot of times,
you can't actually
do things because you can't
be in two places at one
time, things like that.
But just the minutia
of knowing how
to frame a response to somebody,
you can seek out help for that.
And it can be very useful.
ELIZABETH ANCARANA: We
probably have time for one more
question, if anyone has any.
OK, well this was
really informative.
Really wonderful.
Thank you to all three
of our panelists,
Katia, Jay, and Laurence.
We have time for about
a 15 minute break,
but we're going to start
again right promptly at 3:45
with our tenured faculty panel.